herzlich willkommen glasperlenspiel wie
ist die lage alles oft kurz alles super
also schönen köln und freuen uns sehr
dass das hier geklappt hat und aber uns
ist also jetzt steht alles eine
statische für die zweite platte und es
gibt bald wieder los wir sind ja
zusammen gekommen weil wir mitmachen
oder ehren mitmachen kann man die sagen
mitmachen so die anderen aber wir
unterstützen einen wettbewerb 361 grad
respekt man kann videos einreichen und
zwar zum thema gegen mobbing für
toleranz wie seid ihr dazu gekommen wie
die jungfrau zum kinde oder ist das
etwas im thema wo er sagt da haben wir
was zu sagen es war auf jeden fall ganz
witzig also wir haben auf unserer
aktuellen platte einen song geschrieben
und dieser song den hat youtube zu
wirklichen hände bekommen und habe mir
gehört und haben das hat einfach sehr
gut gepasst zu diesem thema und der song
heißt lasst uns was bewegen und die
sonderfonds zu bekommen haben gefragt ob
uns das prinzipiell vorstellen könnte
neben der zusammenarbeit
ob wir die kampagne kennen und ich
kannte sich tatsächlich und ich habe
auch die jahre davor die bands auch
verfolgt die das schon mitgemacht haben
und wo uns das system auch einfach sehr
wichtig doch warum wir auch einen song
darüber geschrieben haben und dann war
das eigentlich auch gleich klar das
passt perfekt wir sind dabei also wenn
man sowas unterstützen kann es natürlich
immer eine super sache
ja ich denke dass es oft schwierig ist
aber wie schon gesagt ich glaube das ist
wichtig dass lehrer dann noch ein
bisschen mehr gucken hat es gibt
bestimmt noch lehrer die sich darum
kümmern aber es ist oft so dass das
natürlich auch schwer ist es zu
entdecken sowie eine klasse ab 30
schüler und dann die auf jeden einzelnen
guckt man ja auch nicht oder man kriegt
es ja auch nicht mit weil so hintenrum
ist und niemand sagt was aber genau
deswegen finde ich auch wichtig dass man
dass man den schülern sagt wie wichtig
es ist und wenn sie dann das gefühl gibt
dass man dass man auch helfen kann und
dass man auch helfen will und möchte
dass es wichtig ist auch für die andere
person oder für die gemobbte person ja
und also da setzt auch dieser brand als
ich gerade 361 grad richtig an und
einfach ein bewusstsein zu schaffen
dafür dass es nicht cool ist und dass
ich glaube wenn du schon wirklich dann
wenn da einfach
sehr viele leute hervor gehen und sagen
sechs mal wenn ich morgens oder so dann
sage ich hey das ist nicht gut auf
ich hab das habe ich auch eine brille
bekommen so in der in der achten klasse
und dann hieß es natürlich von den jungs
brillenschlange hier immer immer den
hier gemacht und soll ich das super
vielen dank natürlich ist es so dass man
nicht da nicht welchen raus und es ist
auch einfach jemanden wegen seiner
schwächen zu kritisieren und einfach bei
den schweizer bei den stärken vielleicht
kann sie zu ignorieren und zu sagen okay
ich mache ich jetzt fertig war eine
brille hast weil mir das vielleicht
nicht passt und weil das gerade alle
lustig finden und ich denke dass es auch
oft in dem alter ist dass es die jungs
vor allem auch machen weil sie sich
dadurch stärker führen oder irgendwelche
schwächen selber kompensieren müssen
oder ich weiß es nicht
ja ich hab da einfach über das
geschrieben als über meinen vater
geschrieben was ich mit ihm erlebt hat
und dann ja das ist für die geschichte
dahinter ist es kannst du es jetzt schon
sagen oder einfach ja meine eltern haben
sich getrennt und ich habe meinem vater
ist nicht so guten kontakt und das war
dann einfach so was mir auf der seele
lag und darüber habe ich dann als ich
habe quasi auch ihnen angesprochenen dem
song und ich habe auch freundinnen die
gesagt haben das ist total super weil
die haben dass ich den geschrieben hat
eben weil die haben das auch so selber
erlebt und das war dann einfach auch so
ein bisschen für mich auch also es tut
einem gutes zu schreiben ist es ein
bisschen so wenn man sowas einer großen
menge menschen erzählt ist es etwa auch
eine befreiung
ja ich bin ich bin mal gespannt wie das
sein wird ein konzept das ich weiß jetzt
ich weiß es jetzt auch nicht also wenn
ich jetzt auf platte höher oder als im
studio eingesungen hat und da
geschrieben habe was natürlich schon ein
stück weit eine befreiung oder irgendwie
schön dass man auszusprechen so aber ist
auch einen konzerten weiß es noch nicht
weiß schon sehr persönlich ist und wenn
ein land so viele leute angucken
ich bin jetzt mal gespannt also wie das
für ein gefühl wird oder das ist ein
gefühl